the nba players association and the
league have
agreed to resume playoff basketball on
saturday they also released a joint
statement with the list of initiatives
they plan to encounter and confront
in the coming days now we welcome in
from the campus in orlando stephanie
reddy who's done a remarkable job
covering everything in there keeping us
updated on all things nba we saw that
there are a number of media available
availability cancellations today
stephanie shed some light on what's
going on with the cancellations
yeah hey ro um you know we were here
this morning just set up to
try and speak to players because as you
all know there really has been nothing
said
publicly and officially on record from
any of these nba players
and just to give you some context the
last official media availability for any
nba player
was when the clippers held media
availability 48 hours ago
that was wednesday at 1pm when marcus
mora senior
did make himself available after head
coach dr rivers and i bring that up
simply not just to tell you the timeline
but also because one of the questions i
was asked of marcus at that time
was what will you do they've heard about
the toronto and boston
teams discussing the possibility of
setting out games at that point
and he said very standard that he stands
with them whatever they decide to do so
that was kind of an
inclination of where the heads were of
these players that they all were going
to have a united front
fast forward 48 hours later and chris
paul as you all just showed
did have a public official statement now
it's interesting because when you're
talking about nba playoffs nba
in season media availabilities they're
often twice a day
we had 48 hours of darkness not a single
player
made a public official statement to me
that was stark
i've been covering this league for a
long time and when you're talking about
everyone in the same
place at the same time i've never seen
anything like that before
now that these statements have been made
i've been told that
all of the rest of the media
availabilities for the remaining teams
that have practice this afternoon
will be available i have not been able
to independently confirm
each specific team but the ones that i
have gotten confirmation from said yes
they will have their media
availabilities
and i've been told also by a league
source that they are expected
all of the remaining teams this
afternoon will have their media
availability so it will be interesting
to hear from players now directly
excellent perspective right there and
one thing we know for sure
that there's been a lot of uncertainty
but one thing that we do know there's
plenty of unity with the players right
now steph thanks for joining us we look
forward to hearing
from you again later today